welcome to mannequin I am a little sick
but I'm feeling a lot better than I was
so I'm going to record a little
something this is mannequin and as you
can see there are mannequins in the
store and if you know me from my history
I don't like mannequins very much at all
so I figure this is going to be an
enjoyable experience for you and maybe
the adrenaline can shock some uh energy
back into my soul because I'm feeling
very unenergetic also we got a new cloak
drop this weekend and I was supposed to
film something very profound and very
robust and extremely captivating an
incredible piece of content
um
Lexi and you got that right
you got that
the link is in the description if you
want to check out the new Arcana drop
it's it it's great it is and you can get
new designs and there's new tarot cards
and it's it's
so go check it out but anyway enough
stalling this is mannequin
well this door isn't at all
altered
yeah excuse me but
it shouldn't matter if I bought these
clothes three months ago
and this store as well
what
cursed me
curse me
like I even care to make anyone happy
go home old lady
I don't know something about a curse
doesn't seem so good oh God why is the
mouse sensitivity always so high you oh
no that's better
all right um
so
what the hell oh no I need to check the
circuit in the back
oh no
okay don't do anything
okay that one's not so bad because I
think I can't see their eyes
huh well this probably isn't good
you know most stores are built like a
maze
they really
why what just happened
that's fine
okay not there hi
anybody in the changing rooms good good
oh yeah yeah navigating easily would
just be a detriment to the shopping
experience
uh-huh
why are all these size L to XXL
okay
electric doors what do you mean the desk
why does a clothing store need to have
such sophisticated security systems like
electronic doors from Five Nights at
Freddy's
and even those were open when the power
went out
oh you yeah that's
that's fine
this is all very good and fine nope
pardon me
all right I have the key
good for me
isn't there another way back there
oh
that's a problem
all right no
so you're active now oh wait wait a
minute
oh it's a big tough mannequin huh you
see Chicago
lipstick oh you're way too fast holy
crap
well that's not good
oh my God wait a minute what the
heck
what the heck
okay
oh yeah
oh that's fine oh that's good oh that's
so good
oh exit
oh I'm sure this is definitely gonna
just let me go
oh
no
all right oh oh
boy
all right
oh oh uncomfy
yeah
it's fine I don't need to look
good oh wait come back wait a minute
well that was weird
don't know why that happened
yeah
back rooms
I bang no clipped
oh no
no hey I have a phone oh that's been my
phone this whole time all right well
I guess I'm going to be wandering the
back rooms for all eternity
no
huh
hello
okay nothing for that
whole lot of no okay
yeah calm your breathing there we're not
dead yet so hold on to your balls
we're getting there we're gonna get out
of here
I definitely should go towards the exit
but there's this tempting side room here
that I can't help but go down
oh wait a minute you're not supposed to
be able to move well wait a minute
wait a minute
ew funky
stop oh
that's fine that's so fine
very fine
okay well I seem to be
you're safe and sound
well I don't know what to do about that
you Stompy bastard
stop
what do I do am I dead can I can run
okay uh look out you wouldn't want to go
through the metal detector
you wouldn't wanna
oh no
no well
oh okay we're fine
I probably seriously it's gone for the
exit
well well wait a minute hold on wait
wait a minute it
plant bench desk dresser shelf man I am
out throw myself away
can you catch your breath I don't like
listening to you
oh perfect
I must have misread it the first time
well that's not good I'm just gonna go
I'm not even gonna look I'm not even
gonna look why would I look oh
oh God no hey
wait a minute
I'm free oh I'm not free
oh
okay so the lesson here is that the poor
service worker uh dies and was cursed
because of a mean old lady and that's
the lesson that's what I remember out of
um being in customer service myself when
I had to do returns and it was um
horrible
anyway thank you so much for watching I
know it's a short video but I'm uh I'm
still recovering a little bit and I
gotta get ahead on things and I gotta
get back into the swing of things lost
out a week of of recording and editing
and I haven't been able to get back in
there but I've been playing a lot of
games on the couch because that's about
as much as I can do sit on the couch and
then play video games so that's been
nice except for the sick part but uh I'm
getting better don't worry about me I'm
feeling all right thank you everybody so
much for watching there's plenty of
other scary games to watch through the
link in the description below we have a
new cloak drop through the link in the
description below and you can check out
the latest distractible animated through
the link in the description below or
just on my channel see ya Bob's first
kiss very
very well made thank you and as always I
will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]